[Music]
the american dream is fading only half
of kids today will go on to earn more
than their parents did
why has this happened and how can we
reverse the fading of the american dream
when thinking about how to answer these
questions you might not think of big
data as a place to look big data is
often associated with corporations
seeking to improve the products they
offer by collecting troves of data on
their customers
but what if we could use big data for
social good to address problems such as
the fading american dream growing income
inequality or persistent racial
disparities
this course will teach you how to use
big data coupled with the tools of data
science and economics to solve some of
the most important social problems of
our time
so the tools that you're going to learn
in this class will be applicable not
just to the types of problems that we'll
discuss here in the united states but
globally around the world
big data helps us cut through
politically charged debates and find out
what policies actually work from a
scientific perspective making the often
discussed notion of evidence-based
policy making a reality
big social problems require big data
solutions